tell me about your oh my so yeah so i
flew out there and then amal
easton who i started with and then uh
elliott marshall who run the school at
easter
who's the who who is the gracie uh
hansel gracie i'm all easton's
he's one of his descendants when you
when you come out of hanso gracie school
real deal yeah you got all your real
real deal and you're done yeah so
chappelle a lot of different schools you
can come out of with a black belt uh-huh
when you come out of a if you come out
of
hansa gracie's school with a black belt
or even a purple belt it
you wouldn't be like in that purple
is right below black there's brown and
then there's there's black but
white blue purple brown black oh yeah
but why don't i think that it takes you
ten years to get
ten years minimum to get blackberry to
get yeah this is a guy who trained
fought in the ufc and
he told me how he had to do it and i was
like because you haven't you haven't
gotten down like that
in a minute it rolled like that hardcore
in a hot second yeah
black belt oh honestly i looked at my
dad i went i haven't rolled competitive
like this in about two years dad
i said we'll see how this goes tiger's
watching he's against the cage i'm like
you guys you guys are right there
rolling yeah in other words you you
still don't want to get tapped
no i don't know but then it's like a
mall clearly black
he just won worlds no gui worlds it
masters
elliot who's a [ __ ] monster damn and
then cody who's a monster
yeah look at it right here the hunched
over christian what are you talking
about
well that no i'm hunched over how you
might well christian christian so that
guy right there christian allen
which one he's an actual ninja they get
uh second to the right he's
that's that's right that guy right there
is the baddest mother like he
he he cody told me that cody look at how
big hoodies he's 235
yep he kicked him in the back of the
neck and he had to sit down for for an
hour like that guy can
you know the little guy that can beat up
huge guys that's that guy he's that guy
he's that good in that guy and his his
his creation
in uh corey sandhagen yeah and he's
fighting tj now that's a different but
all those guys have
all those guys haven't been together in
a hot second they all came together for
this so
oh lauren was there landau oh yeah he's
on the picture lauren was there love
lauren
hit strength conditioning coach for the
broncos yeah the whole squad
i got emotional man when they give him a
bike but i started crying you did did
you yeah
because christian was like man we've had
some great times
you have too yeah the best because you
when you walked in there people should
know that when you walked into that gym
you were lost
oh yeah football dream shattered
nightmare you know what i mean like just
didn't know what you were going to do
played tried to play like some indoor
[ __ ] but like people don't realize what
what that is your whole life dedicated
to something and it goes away
i guess i'll try this yeah you were you
explaining it to me earlier
what you said it's like they're like oh
you get this for six years or something
like that
oh i'd say in professional sports
professional yeah yeah yeah well not bad
too but
professional sports like um i told
chappelle
like imagine if they were like this how
professional sports careers work for the
most part like even if you had a good
career let's say six years in the nfl
yeah good career
so if someone can't do it all right
brian from 2021
to 2027 and then after 27 you gotta stop
headlining you gotta figure something
else out
but put you but if you don't put all
your effort into headlining
you're not gonna be [ __ ] so you can't
really do a side gig
because to make it as a headliner you
got to put all your effort into it
it's fast so professional sports it's
like yeah it's you know six years
i talked to i had bruce grankowski you
know bruce do you know bruce gray caskey
played behind
roethlisberger in pittsburgh and played
in the uh he was a football yeah what
about
tulsa uh toledo a quarterback for eleven
yeah he was good
yeah but never like the guy yeah well he
was behind somebody yeah
but he's a good [ __ ] player great
talking what what
smartest guys on the field are usually
the backup quarterback he's very
real really smart but you just don't
have the athleticism or the game
experience is the best
yeah like the starters just a different
thing man it was it was interesting to
talk to him i love talking to those guys
about the ins and outs of football like
the details because i i
it's so intricate there's so many things
against you if you play for 11 years
if you even make the nfl that's why
people don't realize like
that that in itself is well like for
instance you get a black belt
less than one percent of all people who
start juicing get a black belt yeah
because it's so you have to stick with
it man think about doing some for 10
years
yeah but also not as a profession like
it's just you're just doing it yeah
typically you kind of have to compete in
something don't you tip
nothing it depends on the school right
my school obviously yeah you gotta
compete
yeah certain like there's there's black
people specifically you have to yes well
monsters come out there's black belt
there's there's black belts out there
i've never competed really
like school but why is why is that
[Music]
they don't they you know there's gonna
that's a choice
like these guys with all sorts of black
belts have never competed taekwondo
that's just a choice yeah got it okay
something against them
okay to compete it's like a full time
but even and then i think even to get
your brown but it's like
less than two percent get brown belt
it's just a beat
when you were rolling were you the
biggest guy there ellie's bigger than me
is he really yeah he's bigger
probably yeah was that the guy in the
yeah what was that like though did you
gasp
no i didn't i was so worried you work
out all the time yeah i know
and you bike a lot i bike a lot so my
cardio is pretty good
and and and did it is it like riding a
bike did it all come back
but you know you know what's interesting
is you know jitsu now i think dana heard
i didn't listen to her but danaher was
on rogan i would assume they talked
about it but all these guys were talking
about it
the game now is different it's leg locks
like that that tunnel of leg locks like
all that leg lock [ __ ]
that's what they he's like that's what
all the kids are into now he's like
you know it's just a different animal
it's a whole different thing
all those guys are crushing them man
like like amal just you know his name's
on it and he built the school
he's just doing his thing and then
getting checks and then elliot runs the
school
the biggest school out there and then uh
christian and cody own high altitude
martial arts they own that gym that's
over 600 students now
when when when i left it had this credit
to cody and his wife and christian
when i left they had 29 paying students
wow that's 600 we talked to him about
that like he's a very good teacher well
think
think about when he was out here he was
thinking about moving to l.a i was like
you need to open up your own school dude
you're a great coach you said that
because he was thinking about joining
the fbi he's always been a great coach
then elliot with my son my son learned
more in
freaking 30 minutes working with elliot
he's ever learned in his life
he's such a good coach man of course and
then here's
this guy on the right jeff suskin
again when i was fighting i was in you
know just because you see that i was on
tv and you know
my first fight was the main event i
didn't have a ton of money man i
couldn't pay for privates
so this guy on the right who's a
blackburn far right far right
jeff suskin would work would meet with
me three to four times a week and do
privates wow two hour long privates wow
just to teach me the the
like because i had to catch up i had to
catch up
but the first thing i learned was darts
so like me and christopher talking about
you know i was only training for like a
year but i had a world-class dars
because he taught me like
how to be really dangerous i just had
this knack for darces
so i'd enter the black belt competitions
in the absolute and beat these black
belts because i had a world-class darsh
but if you asked me to do the basics
like
shrimp side escape i didn't have it
but i had but i had it you did that to
matt mitrione yeah i had it well
by the time i got to matt i was a legit
black belt but yeah but early on i just
had the darts
yeah but then so christian feels that
but then suskin would
constantly work with me constantly
working me at easton's in denver
i don't give a damn that you haven't
done it in a minute no no
my my only religion but what's crazy
this too is as i was flying back i text
uh suskin was like dude now i'm older
the amount of time and effort you put in
the guy you didn't know dude
is insane that's one of the best people
i know dude it's insane yeah think about
that
think about taking incredible two hours
a year and he's
i mean where would you have been too
look at the difference he made like just
just
that selfless person like that but he
saw potential in you and then that was
the yeah i started crying when i get my
black belt straight up start crying
i'm blaming it and then cody donovan
goes dude do you remember when you first
came in 2007 so maybe
late 2006 i came to high altitude i was
just a big dude and there's like small
guys then i [ __ ] this small guy
you know by accident i'm like a
guillotine i didn't know and he goes
bam bam straight yeah he goes but he's
cody's friend tell me is wait to my
friend [ __ ] cody
he's gonna [ __ ] you up was like oh my
god what then cody walks in me and cody
your best friend since day one
cause he's like what's up dudes and
we're your best friends
yeah i mean cody didn't skip a beat
that's that's friends
who's as strong as he doesn't know
anything he'd just go oh
he was like a purple belt he's like my
friend cody comes he's gonna [ __ ] you up
i think cody comes with best friends you
know the one thing i'm sorry about is i
never went down the rabbit hole of jiu
jitsu by the time i came to it i was i
think i was just too old
you're just too busy you're busy yeah
it's such a beautiful it's infinite
like it's infinite it's an art form i've
tried it you got it did you
oh you started you could have really
planned for yeah send me there
it's that's what rogan recommends it for
everybody yeah i know
i don't i disagree with him on a lot of
that stuff well he was you know he was
saying because he's like oh because your
cheer background cause you can do it all
flips
i mean it's just different but to me
i'll ask what do you want to do
exactly because if your goal is to learn
jiu jitsu and you're really into jutsu
yeah
jujitsu it's gonna be a ten year process
yeah but if it's to get in shape
don't do it it was around the time to go
kickboxing
kick it back for 10 minutes let me know
how you do it what's like around the top
just hard on your body too i mean it can
be it can be but also just takes a
long time to get good and get fun it
takes a long time
well plus around the time he like you
know sent me through it out like i
didn't have any money or anything like
that that's the other thing it was just
like
it's expensive and i was like you know
like don't get wrong like it was it was
pretty cool and
interesting to learn but i was just like
man this is i was like
it's just like i was like i moved out
here with stand-up comedy you know like
not
and not even like to disrespect that you
know i gave it a shot but
but it's just it's just like commitment
and then you gotta you look at the pay
250
a month probably yeah most schools you
know what i do
you know this weekend i went down the
rabbit hole of john donahue and i lit he
he gives these like
talks like these philosophical talks
about man's
man for a long time had to fight for
survival
and once we mastered that the need
shifted to meaning
and it's really hard to find meaning
and he's the simplest too you know that
he's oh he only has a minimalist yeah
he has like one spoon one bowl he wears
a raspberry
always john donner he's got his i think
he's got his phd starter johnny where's
viewers
like with khakis everywhere he goes
[Laughter]
someone saw him at a bar in that yeah
i've seen him
every time i see him in new york he was
always i saw him at whole foods
yeah hilarious he was on rogue oh it's
almost like
it's almost like a universe he's a
[ __ ] all the big jiu-jitsu guys now
come out of that come
under him and where's that at gordon
ryan
that dude taps the best world like he's
moving like this he's just like dude
like cale sanderson used to struggle
with craig kids
where's where's he located new york new
york manhattan
just unbelievable man damn